if a commodities trader were to tell you
that a market is in contango they're
just referring to the idea that it is
cheaper today so if you're talking about
now it's cheaper to buy that commodity
on the spot market so it's cheaper to
buy it on the spot market than it is to
agree to buy it at some futures date or
some future date using a futures or
forward contract so in the future in the
future it is more expensive it is more
expensive so let's say that that
commodity is gold and I'll just make up
gold prices for the sake of simplicity
this isn't the current gold prices let's
say that today you can go on the spot
market and buy gold at $1,500 at $1,500
per per ounce but if you wanted to buy
gold if you don't want the gold today
and you want to enter a futures contract
to buy the gold one year from now so
let's say the future is now one year
later one year from now instead of
buying that let me write this down this
is the spot market instead of buying it
in the spot market for $1,500 an ounce
you could agree to buy it one year later
one year from now for $1,600 an ounce
$1,600 an ounce and so to a trader this
would be a market in contango and what I
want to point out is that this isn't
that strange of a thing because if you
think about it you have two options if
you want to invest in gold and gold is
something that you want to invest for
the long term you're not going to eat
the gold you're not going to use it to
fuel your cars or anything like that
so in the situation with gold let's say
you want to keep gold for definitely a
year but maybe many many many years so
you have two ways of making that
investment you could take your $1,500
and buy the gold today but if you take
your $1,500 and buy the gold today you
would lose the returns on that $1,500 on
that cash that you could invest other
places so you have the opportunity cost
of the cash so had you invested that
cash someplace else and you also have to
store that gold in the case of gold
storage you have to find some place to
really secure and maybe you need to
ensure the gold and you just
people can't steal it in all the rest so
you also have the storage cost storage
cost in general you could save both of
these costs you could if you enter into
the futures contract so instead of just
buying fifteen hundred dollars in the
spot market today you could enter into
this contract where you can definitely
buy the gold one year later for sixteen
hundred dollars an ounce and then you
could take your fifteen hundred dollars
you could take your fifteen hundred
dollars and get interest on it you could
get interest on it
so that will grow and you'll also save
money on the storage cost so in either
way especially for commodities like gold
precious metals things that aren't
consumable things that people don't need
immediately for consumption it's not
unusual for a market to be in contango
sometimes you might see a severe
contango maybe with something that is
consumable so maybe right now oil is
trading at $50 a barrel once again I'm
just making up the number and in the
future it the futures price is at a
hundred and fifty dollars so this is
probably taking more into account than
just the storage cost and the
opportunity cost of your cash and this
might be because there's a surplus
there's a surplus for oil consumption
today there's just a big glutton the
mark and people are just trying to dump
it or there might be some type of
perceived shortage in the future so you
could think about it either way but this
is very unusual this type of severe
contango is very very unusual unusual
you would you would expect to see kind
of minor ones things that take this cost
into consideration but not something
like this and something like this you
can usually arbitrage it out and make
some money assuming you can store oil or
you have oil to sell or or buy and all
the rest of all the rest of that